so now we're going to use the initial
conditions to figure out our values our
two constant values a1 and a2
that is in our proposed
solution for current for the lc circuit
so one thing we need to do because this
is a second order equation
we need to have two initial conditions
for the variable that we're studying
here so we're studying i right now we
have one initial condition for i and
because we have a second order equation
that means we need two ics
for i
so we have one initial condition right
here and what we'd like to know is what
is d i
d t
at time equals zero
so the other piece of information we
have is this v v naught at time equals
zero so let's use that
and we'll just plug that straight into
the inductor equation so the inductor
equation at t equals 0
the voltage across the inductor is v
naught
and that equals l
times di
dt
all right and that means that d i
d t
equals
v naught
over l
so now i have two initial conditions
in in terms of i there's one
and there's one there
and we can use these now to go after a
one and a2
first off let's plug in i for time
equals zero
and then see if we can work out
something over here
so that means at time equals zero the
current is zero
and that equals a one
cosine
omega naught times
t of zero times zero
plus
a2
times sine
of
omega naught
times 0
and what does this evaluate to
okay this is sine of 0
and sine of 0 is
and cosine of
is
one
so that comes up with zero equals
a one
okay
and a and a one equals zero
means that this entire term of our
solution
just dropped out
all right let me write what we end up
with
i equals a2
sine omega t
omega naught t
this whole term here
just dropped out of the solution so
here's our proposed solution down here
now we need to go after
a2 let's do that
as you might suspect we're going to use
our second initial condition to do that
so to use our initial condition we need
d i d t so let's take d i d t of this so
we're going to take
d
dt
of this whole equation
and on the left side we'll get
d i
d t
and on the other side we'll get
d
dt of
a2
sine omega naught t
okay so far so good let's roll it down
again
so let's take that derivative we get di
dt
equals
a2 comes out of the derivative
and the derivative of sine omega naught
t with respect to t is
omega naught times
cosine
omega naught t
and we apply
our initial condition let's go to t
equals zero
and we know that d i d t was
v naught over l
equals a two
omega naught
cosine of omega naught
times
zero
and cosine of zero
goes to one
and so we can solve for a2 a2
equals
v naught over l
and omega naught goes down here
so now we solve for our second
adjustable parameter and we can write i
i was
a2
sine omega naught t
so let's fill it in for a2 i equals a2
is v naught
over
l
omega naught times
sine omega naught t
and i want to go back now i want to
write this a little bit different i want
to go back and plug in our value for
omega naught
so if we remember we said omega naught
equals 1 over
l
c and the square root of that whole
thing
so now l omega naught
equals
square root of 1 over lc
times
l
and that equals
square root of
l
squared over lc
and that
equals root of l over c
lastly i'll write
1 over
l omega naught
equals
square root of
c over l just the reciprocal
and now we can write i
equals
square root of c over l
times
v naught
sine of
omega naught t
and that
is the solution
for the natural response of an lc
circuit
it's in the form of a sine wave and the
frequency is determined by
omega naught which is the two component
values
and the amplitude is determined by the
energy we started with which is
represented here by v naught
and
the ratio of the two components again
so this is why i said at the beginning
that this is where
sine waves are born